i really never
experienced that before i didn't know
people just
pooped in the
tub that's khloe kardashian getting
candid about her daughter true's messy
bath time mishap
during an all-new episode of ellen
degeneres's digital series mom
confessions what's something you've had
to learn on the fly as a parent
the time a true pooped in the bathtub it
was disgusting and
ugh i don't want to relive it but yeah i
had to learn that on the fly the show
features famous moms answering some of
the harder questions about motherhood
and coco did not hold back
even revealing the trait of her own she
wishes her three-year-old daughter
wouldn't have inherited i am incredibly
clean and organized i like everything in
its place
i'm very regimented and i don't want
that for true but she already has so
much of that i feel bad that she has so
much of it so young but every toy has to
be put back exactly where she got it
from not from me that's what she does
and i
always just try to mess things up and
tell her it's okay to live in a mess
coco also spilled the tea on the
parenting hack she picked up from her
own mom kris jenner parenting trick you
learn from your own mom
if you don't want something just say
you're allergic
and then how can they prove you wrong
and can you guess which kardashian
sister or sisters chloe's referring to
when discussing their different
parenting styles what's the biggest
difference between you and your sister's
parenting styles
um
i am really strict i have a schedule i'm
very militant with how
i parent true and i believe that a
schedule saves everything and not all of
my siblings are the same i will not tell
you which ones
chloe's not naming names but kim did
make her own mom confession back in
october my biggest parenting fail is i
give in too easily sometimes and bribes
i'm guilty of a good bribe e.t has
gotten some mom confessions out of the
kardashians over the years too including
this one from chloe back in 2019 shortly
after true's first birthday the revenge
body host told us about her post-baby
body journey and well it's nothing short
of inspiring what's it been like for you
to see your your post baby body on
camera to be on that journey what's your
relationship with your body like now
it's funny because seeing at the
beginning of all the episodes i have my
sit down with them and i'm a little
bigger because it was closest to when i
just had true and then at the end their
reveals you kind of see my reveals to
even though it's not about me but oh my
god i look so much skinnier because
you're working at the same time right
and it's
that's interesting to see but i'm i felt
really good right after true too i was
really proud of myself how
i thought i would be a little more
insecure because i worked so hard to get
my body before i got pregnant um and i
i felt really good i think after you
have a baby you just feel empowered and
just the fact that you're now able to
juggle a child working out and work i
think that's an accomplishment so i felt
really good that i found my groove and
that i was trying
[Music]
you